so you like the house we just got
curious like those like yeah and just
and just see you again Sunshine's I can
see exactly what's what I've guests come
up I can see them coming I'm just a here
no I think he was when you arrived I was
out the window you know so I love this
doesn't these these nice as well
yeah nice drawers but you know it's more
important you know it's more important
in this big house I mean all-time
favorite is this one yeah the front
cover needs changing but uh I love I
love ran high the best property
investment blocking the water so if
we've got kids over nieces and nephews
they can run Brian here this was a lot
of only first moved in this was not so
bad I know such an echo yeah that's
crazy because when it's everything the
city let go but now
do you bring image to a house or does
the house bring energy to to itself and
to you both
Dinks are like a relationship yeah it
works how important to you is
environment and and wait where you live
where you work
it's like the most important thing
because your environment is what set of
habits yeah it's what sets the thought
process yeah and you go every morning
you see mess when you think about them
yeah that's the thing is that when I
talk about in business I'm sure we need
it as well I love working but from a
very different space and I grew a
business from that and if I james caan
start this business from a broom
cupboard always on to post off my small
place do you think that you can continue
to grow because me I thought when I'm
home and I'm working for me out on my
studio it's gonna be built here obvious
coming around I got people coming over
that beam from a nice space I just know
you just function better
yeah function more from the position of
abundance I don't know how you grow
really big business and inspire people
and lead people in a really smooth
contain space I just think it would be
difficult it's look ever
it's everything's subconscious you know
like if you live we work in London every
hours a siren moment yeah it's like you
don't feel it but all the time you feel
it so a spacey stress as well so it's
unnecessary like when you wake up in the
morning you're sunshine coming through
you see the Rays you see the mist coming
from the grass you open the door it's
quiet you think you know and you've got
all this other stuff it's kind of like
talk it's like kind of like when you
have a conversation someone and you've
got the music in the background you got
the TV everything you like you can have
a conversation but in the back it's kind
of like it's distracting you know I
think it might be as well for me I think
these justification I want to look at a
good house yeah it's same as a car yeah
like you know what if I have a nice car
yeah I'm gonna feel better
I'm gonna get more done don't be a good
return on investment yeah but then I'm
not sure
we had food is but at least even
justifies the cost better yeah
no don't forget you've you've still got
that it's the thought process to
realization so when you think about it
you've got in this here it's real yeah
and it's always playing that big again
so you can stay small and be small or
you can play big and achieve my house
before this was more average she's a
nice house now it's not like a
ridiculous now for eleven years I've
been a millionaire for four years yeah
but you just hold off hold off hold off
but at some point we can hold off
forever
if you hold off forever and live really
baloney means then you're gonna be like
oh man
I'm dead what for me one of the reasons
I wanted to move to this area just a
sort of a number but we're
Buckinghamshire beckons bill
it's because I wanted to be around good
people yeah I wanted to be in London
because that's where people are at
that's where it's an energy that vibrate
in them yeah in the Midlands there's
nothing wrong with the Midlands it was a
also I wanted to move really far away
from my property investments because it
would force me to systemize the heck out
yeah and from in London yeah I'm never
gonna be driving back just sort of
telling spawn now have to give really
good systems in place yeah so I just
thought where the most beautiful place
with wonderful people nice calm peaceful
not Richmond with planes gonna in my
head all the time we found this place
found this house energy was great no I
hear ya Lounge
[Music]
nice all books lying around everywhere I
do a little plug for this James Caan
James Caan will be a great guy we did
audible this was a this was a hit last
time right this was here last time last
one this was like empty yeah they won't
show if it smells like you sure how were
you in the decoration and furnishing
photos they were just like I was like I
trust you I'm pretty laid back and then
they just sent me photos of things that
basically they seemed just like those
and stuff and I kind of told them why
light of what yeah of what we like and
then we just said do whatever you want
and the guys have done this will
introduce you to the team because you're
interested in getting them for your
house yeah my wife loves this stuff yeah
she's doing the whole house like we have
a whole tree in a house I'll show you
that all the tree that video so I mean
we do Christmas a little bit early
because I'm gonna be sort of flying
flying away but so that's the Trina OH
oh my gosh ah did we need to go to your
house oh it's yeah so in the middle of
my house breakfast a trims like a big
squares you can walk on together like
balconies and stuff but we put the tree
right in the middle of the house energy
the energy goes down there that she
gorgeous
yeah it's uh and so here I got a little
picture of Kyra down to that it looks
you don't see how big it is but she's
only like this big everything is behind
you you mean bother
how are you going to tell you everything
when you wake up like it's morning out
at the gyms and they're gonna come here
yeah after your 9 o'clock meeting this
morning drivers gonna have to pick me up
at this time have breakfast my wife and
daughter may be here something to have a
workout this morning so it's any kicks
off today how do you think your thought
process yeah
clarity you have so much things coming
to you every single day but your body is
gonna be equipped handling so you gotta
make this boy
using that senior Superman Superman
Returns so he lands on the on the
skyscraper he's at the top he's walking
this guy takes out his gun fires and
hits his eye and he just got bends and
it just falls on the floor it was like
is invincible
yeah so it's like the Annie G's kind of
let your force field in life you know it
sure is it's what keeps us alive every
your the grow more diamond everything in
business vibration isn't it yeah is that
what we put out to universe that's why
if people don't take action they don't
get results yes you ought to take action
is it's a form of energy
I think environment is always stronger
than well power this is movie a Ruby's
bedroom I do it Wow Ruby's room Ruby is
a baby now just turned two years old
nice but it's about the same we just
carry kids almost but she got her own
bed
carry me a fuses to sleep in a bed Jones
comes in to Albert so we've got a big
bed in our bedroom then we have done
another bed next to it Oh mom's loosely
so she always causes she she won't sleep
insanely this was a cot Oh was it
but Ruby managed to get out of the car
but when she'd get out she'd be like in
just at the gate crying out of a car so
we just thought this is turned into a
bed yeah give us some responsibility so
if you're watching the video if ever you
end up somehow coming over my house as a
guest just sleep this will be your bed
I'm gonna sway you yeah
first time I've been in this room since
the last video tall he's he's just like
9 9 10 months so still got a cough so
this is the children's bathroom yeah so
this is where they get back the bedroom
this is where we sleep master bedroom
I just love how quiet and peaceful it is
see this this is nice you see yes and if
you come on in line and also the way
that the windows go right the way up to
the top keeps it really bright yeah I
sometimes just just sit yeah wait for
people thinking though yeah if you like
you watch the birds watch the Sun go up
and down he's a king-sized bed
it doesn't feel king-size because the
room is so big yeah but this is
king-size you have your little sips yeah
and then this is Amanda section yeah and
then the ensuite through here us again
on the back with like greenery in plants
and stuff around which is nice so I mean
it's so beautiful thank you ladies for
all your hard work
I mean we've done nothing yeah so it'd
be fun oh yeah what room are you most
proud of I would say the diving and the
entrance
so we like check them out we'll leave a
link in the description well those of
you watching stuff like this don't come
easy I think a lot of people have
misconceptions especially in you know
the lining industry that worrying about
you know becoming financially free you
know trying to make money do something
set aside hustle and everything comes a
price yeah everything comes at you got
to learn you know put hard-working
nothing you can't get rich just by
clicking your finger it took me 10 years
to list of company and you know I'm a
stock exchange so yeah I took a lot of
investment on a time where there's a lot
of sleepless nights I'm sure the same
for you with the property side and the
other side so you know if anyone
watching this you can inspired right now
you think I yes all right for him you
know it's easy not everyone starts in
the same place everyone starts with like
some social media you know the people I
saw if you don't got millions of
followers not everyone started with one
follow up
yes they're all followers for sure sure
also I think as well this is the kind of
stuff that I put on my dream board when
I was been starting out in business you
know this kind of a house he's kind of
this kind of a design and I think it's
really was a SHINee's important
everything I've visualized in my life
everything where I've been you know if I
want to live in an area I've run around
the streets in the area
the kind of you know the kind of people
I want to work with the kind of money I
want to make the sort of stages I want
to speak out the kind of property
investments that want to have everything
you know I'll write it down our picture
it or visualize it or see it and I think
that's really important and also as well
as well as a dream board I think
personally I think you've got to have a
nightmare board they may live one not
just what you don't want cuz you should
never focus on what you don't want you
can focus on what you do want but I'm
not net board is if I don't put the time
in if I don't get the right training if
I don't put the hours in this is what
life will look like you know and
whatever that might be so yeah not their
board okay fact a fact of the day is
this house Jerry cannot own this was
reckon I read this was the answer
right right why do I rent this place I
read this place because if people
sometimes you know that even even in
even in the comments on my last one it's
just people are saying oh but but do you
just rent this place
do you just rent this place yeah this
this this this this rent is probably
three or four times the average salary
yeah and the reason I rent this place
instead of buying it is I rent it for
ten years okay
I rent the reason I rent this place is
because if I was to buy this house yeah
it would the amount of money enough to
put down I'd be better off instead of
putting that money to buy this house
yeah I developed put that money
elsewhere
invest it yeah in property in little
houses yeah they give me a good win yeah
with all the money that I make off these
lots of houses I rent this house yeah
and have more money left over and if I
earn this house the capital appreciation
will be a little but if I have a lots of
houses the Cubs depreciation suddenly
adds up and it becomes a lot
yeah so it's a commercial viewpoint to
rent this place rather than buy it
I just couldn't justify behind this
house because I drop I'd rather rent it
people say but it's dead money it's not
dead money because the money that I'm
saving in not putting it down to buy it
means I can invest that money well
people don't understand that something
called an opportunity cost so let's say
you from selling your some three four
million to this house
you could have taken that money put into
a stock market you could go a nap with
that you could have them bought
something else that would have created
more so you know the reason we have
bought my place now has come
settling down now yeah and my companies
went public so I have to stay in that
physical location so I know I'll be
there for a long time yeah so I don't
know if I'll be hearing in a year's time
I probably you know I don't know where I
want to be and I want that freedom as
well yeah so but that's exactly what I
did so I used the money from all my
other businesses and all my properties
to pay for the place I'm live now so in
effect even though I own the house and I
put some money into that it's being paid
off by everything else that I'm
producing for all my vehicles of income
yeah when I finished having all the kids
are definitely want to have I know
exactly where I wanna live yeah so yeah
for sure a lot of my students have sold
out houses okay use the money to buy two
or three investment houses and then gone
into rented accommodation yeah so I
won't know if you're watching this do
you own where you live or do you rent
comment below if you're an owner or
renter and I'll judge you if you're an
owner okay I want you to be a renter why
cuz I want you to be the renter of where
you live and the owner of what you rent
out a comment below 11 any thoughts hope
you enjoyed the tour thank you so much
for watching subscribe I'll see you next
time